oh
as I parch I drink
she's done more for Jen than you yeah I
think that's what was brewing because
she is watching you ride for someone
who's being guilty you'll lie to your
face and it's ruining your relationship
with Whitney I don't appreciate being
gaslit by Whitney
I know that I show up for my friends I
know that I have 100 shut up for Whitney
I have never not had your back publicly
or privately when you came up and in the
middle of a trip that was not about you
not about you plus stirring the pot not
about you making a moment talking about
Lisa it was really filming a TV show
okay well then you chose the TV show
over over here
is a compromise of character no but
that's true too that's what's up I have
to agree with Heather if you did it
before TV moment I'm gonna agree with
Heather
I never thought you would compromise our
friendship for a TV moment ever and you
did I know we believed as Mormons a lot
of crazy
but this rumor is too dumb too damaging
for me to sign up for it my Integrity as
a gossiper is affected by this rumor if
I just like blindly sign up and say it's
true it's not true Heather cares more
about looking good on the show and
having her hands clean she handed Mia
grenade took the pin off let me blow up
and walk away before any shrapnel hit
her well I'm just gonna be totally
honest part of me really did not want to
come home
[Music]
let her talk I really had hesitation
coming here because last season was so
hard for me I lost my grandmother the
first week of filming
I have to go to Ramona's house for five
days later grandma just died no she was
dying
I want to set an intention for my family
to find strength because my grandmother
is very sick and passing away right now
no none of my cast members no one said
Leah go
[Music]
there's no way in hell anyone is going
to tell me to sit anywhere if my family
needed me you gotta take responsibility
for what you do and never blame a
producer I mean we have the same
production company and I know them very
well there's no way they would have made
her stay there
insane not one of you guys he was even
giving a and it's up you
bitched are you crazy finally like I
woke up in the morning and I was like I
gotta leave guys and I got in the car
and my mom texted me that she died and I
was on my way to New Jersey okay it's
okay and it catapulted me into the worst
impression I've ever had that I ended up
in a hospital I'm like and then when it
aired the audience is like you should
have been with your grandmother
you are bigger and you are so much more
than whatever experience you had on that
song
why
and why do you want to go home you want
to know why I made a joke just now about
you going home no well you've been
acting like you want to go home girl you
are wild girl you are wild as hell
you're like confronting someone about
your lives what last night you were
saying that you were so bored and I was
bored last night so you say to the whole
damn table why don't y'all get drunk or
something I'm bored can you guys like
get drunk or something Leah says she's
bored oh why don't you guys like order
like we your drunk monkeys or something
like oh we're not entertaining unless
we're drunk yeah right exactly what you
want is that it we're not entertaining
exactly that's what I'm used to people
saying to me because before this trip
even started Marisol texted me being
like I really respect you for not
drinking blah blah
but I wish you were still drinking so I
felt a type of way and maybe I should
have talked to you about it but I didn't
want to bring that into the trip listen
to me you live in a real world people
are going to tell you that kind of stuff
you got to be stronger that though like
oh like you know you should be like
nobody tells me that but like as a joke
why does everyone want me to drink I
don't get it like you're the one that
told me if you don't have a drink in
four hours in the morning your stomach
starts to hurt like I don't want to
Marisol it's like can we just wait till
like noon to drink the Vodka what does
that mean is there like a schedule have
some eggs have a bowl of cereal morning
noon and night it's the schedule as I
parch I drink I can be grateful that you
spoke for me and still wish that I had
the opportunity to speak for myself
you should be more happy that she said
for you because I brought hairstyles
you brought a statement from that
raggedy the only reason I was
going hard on the show is because
Giselle was giving me about Candace as
hard as Candace is going in on me it's
like she's not even realizing that
Giselle had her back she texted it is
still it's hearsay because it's not
first person her perspective University
School of Communications karate class
news
you can have a degree but I have the
journalism job and I can use my job I
can use my mouth and talk about things I
don't have to Google anything we can
move on
it's interesting to watch Porsha
continue to defend her foolishness
instead of just apologizing to me she
hasn't learned from the first time that
she repeated things she knew were true
it's still hurtful that she's doubling
down on really being a bully once again
it's just a Fluff opinion show it's not
you know an investigative reporting that
goes behind us
next up will be Heather Heather's
question is who gave you the black eye
okay she's gonna eat the Scorpion
you know what's so funny you said you
didn't know so you must know no we I we
know that she knows she thinks Jen did
it who thinks Jen did it I do oh yeah me
too I think she's protecting Jen
Whitney must know she must know that I
went to Jen's room and I said Jen I am
the informant and Jen said oh hell no
and just spot me there's only a couple
reasons why Heather would go out of her
way to protect Jen like this either Jen
has something major over Heather or like
attracts like
this is nothing that you're gonna
uncover Nancy Drew oh my God wait I just
can't put my legs yeah it doesn't feel
well you want some water
oh my God you gotta lay her down here
comes the medicine oh you have to put it
back on the floor
like I said
does anyone have any like sugar or gum
or I don't have anything I only have
booze I know nothing
we've got to put her feet up we gotta
put her feet up just keep breathing
underwear
it's okay I'll cover you wearing
underwear okay okay
where's the Pepsi Pepsi's here
oh my God you're okay
Candace is attending to her like a wet
nurse
been there done that I also have
diarrhea today I think I'm dehydrated
maybe yeah now she's nasty Leah
[Laughter]
off of the Mormon roll to other Mormons
means that you pretty much don't exist
you're 15 years ahead of me and you're
gonna now no flip that on me and be like
she's a
on the rolls
I've been reluctant to take my name off
the roles of the church because it just
seems like a flippant aggressive action
having your name on their roster
literally you're still supporting them
because they count you when they Lobby
for bills to be passed or when they're
buying properties when they're building
new temples I mean the way I conduct my
life the way I raise my children those
are the tenets of my faith not my name
on a database somewhere you're saying
that you reject all of these things
about the Mormon church but you're still
endorsing them that seems hypocritical
to me
the Mormon church has filed a trademark
like um objection to me even having
anything about the book like I am on
their radar I'm going to be absolutely
alienated and completely ostracized for
my community and she knows all of them
apologize and stop trying to prove me
wrong I did it everyone's stirring the
pot but if she can't help getting her
name off the road but she already
applied why would you say it's Aaliyah
likes cheese
that is a damaging rumor she just said
to you and she just said to me well I
was just being shady no that's not a
flippant response I tried about that and
you a lot I literally I cannot even
believe that you were just being shady
what impressed
with me
it ain't in my room yeah
or you took it
took it just a minute now just admit it
now give me my bottle
well leaving the room she left with
nothing and I'm like wait let's get the
Gray Goose and the alcohol
I'm turning into a Marisol oh my God
[Music]
foreign
oh boy what huh
what she's gonna throw up what you're
gonna throw up oh oh boy what well she
takes a lot of medication maybe it's on
an empty stomach
this is the worst trip ever
how are you feeling
okay and nauseous
[Music]
did you throw up I'm like it's not
coming out I'm dry heaving like
um have you had been drinking water yes
and that didn't come out either
thank you
do you feel dizzy at all oh my God
please let me just try to throw it
because I feel so nauseous
getting sick in a foreign place is
terrifying I don't know if it's
something she ate something she drank or
just like these evil girls like making
her sick but it sucks like I feel
horrible for her that this is her
experience is this Leah's event this
Temple thing yeah I mean yes it is
okay oh my goodness this is Leah's event
the spirit has taken us so your BP is
good okay girl she just thought so good
so
[Music]
maybe I'll give you some electrolytes
just to make you hydrated you need to
rest oh my God I'm happy that Candace is
checking on me because clearly no one
cares
some of you are on this trip you'll have
a nine-year-old and a 12 year old it's
like a dangerous age you know where
you're forming your children and your
view are you talking about this like
from experience because of your
ex-husband has nothing to do with this I
raise my children on my own are you
judging yeah no I'm not even judging I
really want to know because like as you
were sitting there yesterday after an
after party when you were on the pole
and then the other night we went to the
confessional and I'm super liberal but
you know what else has stopped me what
are my kids gonna think of me what is
the example of giving them I'm just
surprised because you were married to a
cartel members
no my love I was married to the father
of my kids okay
[Music]
thank you